bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
en direct sur figaro live vous le savez
chaque jour nous décryptons pour vous
les événements qui font l'actualité
aujourd'hui nous avons choisi de
commenter la rentrée politique d'
emmanuel macron marquée par le
déplacement du chef de l'état à
marseille vous levez vous venez de le
voir sur ces images une entrée furtive
du président dans l'hôtel de ville de la
ville de marseille et lille macron ce
gens se vient de se rendre aujourd'hui
dans la cité phocéenne où il doit rester
trois jours pour avec le projet d'y
présenter un plan d'urgence pour tenter
de résoudre les problèmes qu'affronte la
deuxième ville de france on pense
évidemment à l'insécurité au trafic de
drogue mais ce ne sont pas les seuls
défis que doit relever la ville de
marseille et auquel le chef de l'état
souhaite apporter des améliorations
on y reviendra dans quelques minutes
d'ici là avec nous pour commenter cette
rentrée politique d' emmanuel macron jim
d'arras et bonjour gilles bouchard
l'autre merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur le figaro là il vous êtes rédacteur
en chef adjoint au service politique du
figaro
et vous allez pouvoir répondre aux
questions des internautes
trois jours dans une seule et même ville
de l'hexagone pour un chef de l'état
français c'est inédit c'est inédit en
effet c'est la première fois que
emmanuel macron passe autant de temps
hors de paris dans un déplacement
présidentiel depuis le début du
quinquennat c'est absolument pas anodin
puisque d'abord c'est sa rentrée
politique c'est à dire qu'on l'avait pas
vu depuis un certain nombre de semaines
il était cet été au fort de brégançon là
tous on a tous vu les photos du chef de
l'état à bormes les mimosas et puis sa
rentrée politique a surtout été marqué
par on va dire le front diplomatique de
la crise afghane avec
voilà des interventions du chef de
l'état une intervention télévisée qui a
été remarquée et puis beaucoup d'
échanges diplomatiques avec les chefs de
l'état les institutions internationales
mais pas de déplacement nationale sur
l'actualité
qui concerne véritablement les français
et puis il ya autre chose c'est
évidemment le fait qu'on soit à huit
mois seulement de l'élection
présidentielle il ya assez peu de doute
sur le fait que emmanuel macron va être
candidat à sa propre succession à
l'elysée est donc évidemment est donc
cette ce premier déplacement de trois
jours
marathon de trois jours à marseille
c'est surtout en déplacement de campagne
on y reviendra effectivement que c'est
évidemment il ya autre chose que cette
visite à marseille sur ces trois jours
un enjeu plus d'amplitude ampleur plus
importante que les enjeux locaux qui
concerne son déplacement et le plan
d'urgence qu'il est censé dévoiler est
ce que ça fait de cette rentrée
politique une rentrée original pour un
chef d'état
à quelques mois d'une échéance
présidentielle comment fonctionnaient
les autres chefs des forces oui c'est
une basse et une entrée originale parce
que justement il ya ce déplacement d'une
vraiment d'une ampleur complètement
exceptionnelle qui en plus va
s'accompagner d'un plan qui est lui même
exceptionnel on parle d'un d'un plan qui
va dépasser le milliard d'euros que
c'est c'est pas du tout anodin alors
c'est pas la première fois que l'état va
présenter un plan d'urgence pour
marseille puisque malheureusement la
deuxième de france est confrontée à des
problèmes depuis déjà plusieurs
décennies
il fallait à ce point
marseille est à ce point en crise est-ce
que le tableau et si son qu'il faille
trois jours de présence du président la
république sur place après ça c'est une
question de perception alors évidemment
l'opposition est minable macron dit que
c'est de la communication politique que
c'est de l'opportunisme politique et que
emmanuel macron utilise sa fonction de
chef de l'état pour faire de la
politique et pour faire campagne sur le
dos de des problèmes de marseille
puisque on va le voir
emmanuel donc on va parler des problèmes
de marseille mais à travers marseille il
va parler de la france de ses idées pour
la france de son programme pour la
france donc bien sûr qu'il ya ceux il ya
ceux il ya sept il ya cet opportunisme
politique qui est qui évidemment présent
mais on peut a contrario penser que les
problèmes marseillais sont elles en
termes de sécurité en termes d'économie
d'emploi de jeunesse d'éducation on
parle d'un salaire égal insalubrité il
ya tellement de problèmes que finalement
passé trois jours à marseille pour
essayer de décortiquer et d'apporter des
réponses concrètes
à plus d'un million de français parce
que c'est ça lag lomé ration marseillais
c'est
ça peut peut-être se justifier on le
voit sur ces images si vous venez nous
rejoindre en direct n'hésitez pas à nous
poser toutes vos questions en rapport
avec ce déplacement inédit d'emmanuel
mâcon et placement inédit pour un chef
d'état français dans une ville et une
métropole française trois jours sur
place à marseille vient d'arriver on l'a
vu entrer très furtivement vous voyez
sur cette rediffusion des images de
l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron dans
l'hôtel de ville à marseille il est
accompagné je crois gym jarrassé de huit
ministres si je me trompe pas oui ça
tout vite en effet puisque c'est des
ministres qui vont eux mêmes aussi
décliné les différents pans du plan
global pour pour marseille donc il ya
bien évidemment gérald darmanin qui est
présent le ministre de l'intérieur qui
va accompagner emmanuel macron dans une
visite de commissariats qui va qui va se
dérouler juste après cette rencontre à
la mairie de marseille il ya également
barbara pompili 1 la mise de l'écologie
puisqu'il sera également question des
coûts environnement les absents il y
sera il sera en effet question
d'environnement vendredi pour le dernier
jour du déplacement des manuels macron
puisque c'est également l'ouverture d'un
congrès de l'union internationale pour
la conservation de la nature donc ça va
être un moment fort et là encore on se
projette dans la campagne présidentielle
puisque c'est l'environnement va être un
enjeu forme de 7,2 cette campagne donc
barbara pompidou est également présente
alors à noter le fait que
monsieur dupont moretti le eric dupond
moretti le ministre de la justice n'est
pas présente mais il avait lui-même fait
sa rentrée politique à marseille il ya
quelques semaines au mois d'août pour
annoncer des renforts de magistrats pour
la pour la cité phocéenne donc là il
n'est parvenu cette fois ci avec
emmanuel macron mais il y aura des
annonces sur le plan de la de
l'actualité judiciaire alors on va
peut-être venir juste sur la ville de
marseille est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
objectif de grandeur également une
volonté de lui donner
nora dans un rayonnement plus important
en méditerranée de la part du chef de
l'état ça a été même théorisé en par
emmanuel macron il s'est exprimé dans la
dans la revue zadig il a parlé de
marseille qui une ville
qui lui est très cher puisque il y
passait ses vacances quand il était
adolescent il est un fan invétéré de
l'olympique de marseille il ne cesse
d'ailleurs de le leur rappeler donc il a
un attachement très fort vis-à-vis de
cette ville et il veut il à dit faire de
marseille la capitale de la méditerranée
c'est à dire la de toutes les rives de
la méditerranée et que ce soit
finalement la véritable deuxième ville
de france c'est à dire avec la même aura
que peu à voir paris mais paris qui est
finalement une ville très centralisé et
très renfermé ans hurle sur la france là
marseille symbole d'ouverture de la
france sur la méditerranée sur les
voisins la matière mais la méditerranée
à commencer par les pays du maghreb avec
la calle avec lesquels la france a
beaucoup de dates h donc c'est ça il ya
aussi renforcé marseille de manière très
pragmatique sur le plan de la sécurité
de l'économie d'une part et puis il ya
aussi je pense une visée culturelle dans
ce dans ce plan présenté par le chef de
l'état pour vraiment redonné une stature
à marseille qui est de marseille qui est
quand même une ville
millénaire historiquement très
importante qui était un lieu d'échangé
de brassage qu'il l'est toujours mais
qui a perdu peut-être un peu de sa
superbe et leur appartement de en
parlant de deux millénaires et de
capitale millénaire on connaît aussi la
rivalité séculaire entre paris et
marseille comment on peut éviter de
donner l'impression finalement que que
la capitale vole au secours de la cité
phocéenne en effet sa dette ou plus tout
le dfid emmanuel macron sur ces trois
jours on va voir la façon dont il va
présenter les annonces de ce plan ce
sera surtout demain lors d'un discours
au palais du pharo il va vraiment
détaillé tous les pans de ce plan de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
le rappel cesser ces gigantesques et
donc il va avoir à coeur de montrer que
finalement l'état n'est pas là pour
justement arrosé marseille 2 millions
d'euros mais vraiment travailler dans
une coopération et une co-construction
du plan c'est également ce qu'a cherché
à montrer benoît vaillant le maire
socialiste de marseille qui entretient
plutôt de bonnes relations avec emmanuel
macron c'est à noter c'est intéressant
politiquement puisque finalement benoît
pagne en arrive à la tête d'une ville
qui est dans une situation très
compliquée on l'a dit on va leur dire
qu'ils exemple financièrement et qui
politiquement est aussi très usés il ya
eu l'héritage du
2 le dos du mandat des mandats de jean
claude gaudin qui était un maire qui a
fait beaucoup de choses pour marseille
mais qui a eu une fin de mandat très
compliqué avec notamment les drames de
la rue d'aubagne deux immeubles qui se
sont effondrés causant le décès de
plusieurs plusieurs personnes et puis il
ya eu l'épisode rubi ball a donc la
maire écologiste de marseille qui a été
qui a été élu en mars dernier et puis ça
s'est pas très bien passé pour elle
puisqu'elle a été contrainte
d'abandonner son mandat assez rapidement
et de repasser le flambeau à son premier
adjoint qui est donc le socialiste
benoît paillon et qui lui cherche à
incarner une position très pragmatique
c'est à dire qu' il va prendre l'aide du
chef de l'état mais essayez d'installer
quand même une relation équilibrée entre
marseille et l'état pour prendre le
meilleur de ce que lui offre
l'état puisqu'il n'a pas fini mais
finalement les moyens de refuser refusé
de l'aide mais tout en étant partie
prenante de l'élaboration de ce plan
donc ça va être très intéressant de voir
la façon dont cette stratégie va être
annoncée mais les marseillais
doivent être partie prenante pour que ça
fonctionne puisqu'il ensuite il ya la
question de l'application du plan
absolue voeux pour que ce plan puisse
fonctionner il faut qu'il soit appliquée
par l'administration marseillaise et
pour ça il faut que l'administration
marseillaise fonctionne et donc il faut
une chaîne
d'applications politique et
administrative efficace on va dire des
mots clés sorte de garde-fou pour
sécuriser aussi la façon dont seront
dépensés les aides qui arriveront aussi
de l'état au sein de denture balance à
ça ça va plutôt être que du côté de
paris qui va surveiller ça parce que en
effet
il faut pas qu'ils aient faut pas qu'on
soit dans une relation de va pas dire
qu'on va pas parler de corruption ni de
clientélisme mais en tout cas que
l'argent soit correctement dépenser et à
des
vrais mans dans l'action et dans
l'amélioration du quotidien des
marseillais puisque en fait il ya eu
tellement de plans déjà pour marseille
jean marc ayrault premier ministre en
2012 et est lui-même venu pendant
plusieurs jours à marseille pour
présenter un implant à grand renfort de
discours etc bon finalement on s'est
rendu compte que ça a pas amélioré trop
la situation donc comme comme vous comme
vous le dites vraiment ça va être la
question de l'application et faire en
sorte que l'argent aille au bon endroit
et finance des choses concrètes pour
vraiment améliorer les écoles les
transports
les le tissu d'entreprises donner des
structures pour les pour les pour les
banlieues pour les quartiers nord de
marseille c'est la santé les hôpitaux
puisque la situation est compliquée
aussi dans les hôpitaux avec le colis
dont on l'a vu tout au long de la crise
tout ça ça va être de la responsabilité
de la mairie de marseille c'est pour ça
que il ya ce lien important qui doit se
crée entre les deux hommes alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à francine
pochon qui nous écrit sur le chat du
figaro live sur youtube ces deux là
comme bof qu'est ce qu'on peut lui dire
à francine parce qu'effectivement
ça peut être perçu comme tel on parlait
de campagne présidentielle à venir on
parlait de l'échéance effectivement de
l'élection en avril prochain
les élus sur place comment perçoivent
t-il effectivement à marseille l'arrivée
du chef de l'état il ya tout ça aussi
peut-être la seule chose qu'on peut se
dire finalement c'est pourquoi avoir
attendu quatre ans c'est à dire que les
problèmes
de marseille on les connaît ils sont
identifiés depuis déjà le début du
quinquennat et même malheureusement
avant alors certes il ya eu cette
accélération
de la violence à marseille et notamment
des homicides on en est à 15 depuis le
début de l'année c'est absolument
terrifiant il ya eu encore trois morts
il y à il ya deux semaines trois jeunes
qui ont été tués au cours d'un au cours
d'un seul week end donc il ya ce
contexte d'insécurité qui ce qui se
développe et qui justifient justement un
coup de poing ferme de la part de l'état
mais finalement pourquoi avoir attendu
quatre ans emmanuel macron aurait très
bien pu dès la première année de son
mandat aurait été d'ailleurs un acte
fort pour commencer son son quinquennat
aller à marseille est présenté ce plan
puisque le diagnostic on l'avait déjà
donc là dessus on peut se dire en effet
réponse à cette question il a peut-être
été posée que répond le chef de l'état
mais le chef de l'état justement ne dit
que
les problèmes ont été seulement
identifié maintenant et que et qu' il
faut les années passées ont été
nécessaires pour travailler vraiment le
plan qu'il va dévoiler oui certainement
enfin pour l'instant il n'a pas encore
vraiment du championnat mais en effet
comme vous comme vous le précisez je
pense que la question va lui et va lui
être posées ça va être ça va être une
réponse à apporter à la aux oppositions
politiques qui sont sur ce terrain là
mais bon il faut quand même être
il faut aussi se dire que finalement
tout politique c'est de la communication
donc oui c'est de la communication
évidemment ce déplacement de trois jours
extra mais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure c'est peut-être à la hauteur des
attentes des marseillais et des enjeux
pour sauver la ville de marseille donc
tout est une question d'interprétation
finalement
selon qu'on considère que macron fait de
la politique ou mac on fait de la
communication mais les deux sont
forcément un peu mêlé alors si vous
venez nous rejoindre en ce moment et en
direct sur figaro live et sur youtube
vous voyez des images que nous vous
diffusons de l'arrivée d' emmanuel
macron le chef de l'état vient d'arriver
dans la cité phocéenne à marseille vient
d'entrer il ya quelques minutes dans la
mairie de marseille il est normalement
accompagné d'un certain nombre de
ministres au total 7 8 on vient de le
voir avec notre expert j'aime bien
passer à côté de moi en direct sur ce
plateau on le disait jim
marseille c'est un choix de coeur on l'a
vu tout à l'heure aussi pour emmanuel
macron qui est très attaché pour des
raisons sentimentales
parce qu'il est passionné par l'om parce
qu'il ya passé une partie de sa jeunesse
parce qu'il aime les marseillais il l'a
dit mais c'est aussi un choix très
politique il ya un intérêt peu plus
politique on sait que c'est aussi le
fief du rassemblement national et puis
de jean luc mélenchon tout à fait en
effet jean luc mélenchon qui devraient
être présents dans cette réunion
puisqu'on l'oublient souvent mais il est
député des bouches du rhône il avait été
un peu parachuté au moment des
législatives
a marseille il avait été élu puisque à
une base assez solide de gauche radicale
dans un marseille d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de noter que finalement aux
élections alors on dit que
finalement le marseille est un fief
macro nice mais finalement les
marseillais ne vote pas trop pour macron
c'est en effet des électeurs qui votent
essentiellement pour marine le pen pour
la droite et pour la gauche radicale
l'électorat mama cronista à marseille
est très limité
si on excepte on va dire les nouveaux
marseillais qui viennent notamment
d'ailleurs beaucoup de paris qui sont
souvent
à ces riches qui sont pas forcément
représentatifs de la population
marseillaise et qui eux ont plutôt
tendance à voter pour emmanuel maquet
d'assurer un potentiel vivier où des
gens dont on pourrait faire
retourner le vote allait garder manuel
mata les séduire suffisamment c'est une
terre sur laquelle emmanuel macron a
beaucoup de progrès électoraux à faire
et encore une fois c'est un réserve de
voix potentiel important puisqu'on parle
de plus d'un million d'électeurs
d'électeurs potentiels urbain et donc
potentiellement des électeurs qui
pourraient voter pour pour emmanuel
macron mais en effet donc on va assister
à un bras de fer politique avec jean luc
mélenchon n'est il y avait déjà eu une
altercation lors d'une dernière venue de
d'emmanuel macron à à marseille avec
jean luc mélenchon qui l'avait traité de
xénophobe il s'était ensuite expliqué
dans la rue savait pas d'ailleurs tourné
vraiment al'avantage de jean-luc
mélenchon donc là on va voir comment
jean luc mélenchon aborde cette cette
séquence et puis vous vous l'avais dit
il ya également l'électorat frontiste
qui est très présent à marseille marine
le pen qui a déjà accusé en effet
emmanuel macron d'opportunisme et qui
vise le le bilan
régalien d'emmanuel macron sur le plan
de la sécurité en disant que que tout ça
c'est des mots et de l'argent mais que
finalement le quotidien
des gens à marseille c'est la violence
c'est les coups de feu dans la rue c'est
le trafic de drogue c'est les zones de
non-droit dans les quartiers nord on a
vu des images encore récent en tout
certaines cités sont complètement
bloqués avec des barrières par départ
des par des dealers et les habitants qui
ne peuvent pas circuler librement c'est
une situation quand même
très grave et donc évidemment
l'opposition a beau jeu d'aller sur ce
terrain là pour tenter d'attaquer le
bilan des manuels à mouscron sur le call
c'est des questions sur lesquels
emmanuel marc on n'est pas forcément
toujours très à l'aise depuis le début
de son quinquennat emmanuel macron agit
et parle beaucoup d'économies il a
beaucoup parlé récemment évidemment la
crise sanitaire mais sur les registres
de du régalien de la sécurité et de la
justice et de la laïcité c'est des
sujets sur lesquels on sent qu'il doit
encore travailler et je pense que ce
déplacement trois jours va être
justement l'occasion pour lui d'offrir
un visage de fermeté
qu'attend d'une partie des français à
l'humain de l'élection et puis il ya
autre chose dont on n'a pas encore parlé
qui est que justement sur cette rentrée
politique il ya une activité très
particulière à gauche et à droite qui
sont les primaires qui sont en train de
se jouer des deux côtés la primaire des
écologistes la primaire des républicains
qui est en train de se lancer les
socialistes qui vont certainement aller
aussi dans un dans un système de
désignation interne donc chaque chaque
chaque camp de l'opposition est en train
est très occupé dans ces petites
bisbilles internes politique finalement
qui n'intéresse pas vraiment les
français qui attendent eux des réponses
concrètes sur
leur vie quotidienne emmanuel macron lui
et ben arrive dans ce contexte là et
montre que lui c'est le président de
l'action qui s'occupe des préoccupations
des gens et donc il va aussi essayer de
marquer une différence avec ses
adversaires politiques sur ce point là
et maniema conte qui est aussi perçu
comme quelqu'un de trop parisien on a
anonyme 70 0 92 qui dit emmanuel éboué
emmanuel macron est à la conquête de la
province pour d'interrogation c'est vrai
que à la différence de ses prédécesseurs
emmanuel macron c'est assez peu déplacé
sur le terrain alors le problème c'est
que
il a quand même connu un quinquennat de
crise avec la crise des gilets jaunes 1
qui s'est ensuite enchaîné sur la crise
sanitaire du cornât virus donc il ya
beaucoup de déplacements qui aurait pu
se faire qui ont été qui ont été annulés
entre avait donc emmanuel macron c'est
vrai que gardent encore cette image d'un
président urbain parisien qui n'est pas
connecté aux territoires et donc je
pense que aussi la symbolique de ces
trois jours passés sur place c'est aussi
montrer que finalement il vient il
s'installe avec armes et bagages sur le
long terme si ces trois jours mais c'est
encore une fois c'est énorme c'est le
c'est quand même le plus long
déplacement dans présents sur le terrain
depuis le début du quinquennat j'ai pas
souvenir
sous le quinquennat de françois hollande
que françois hollande se soit déplacé
aussi longtemps je vis en métropole en
fait évidemment
donc donc oui il veut essayer de briser
cette image là c'est évident on vient de
le voir des images désormais en direct
nous sont fournies par life paix depuis
marseille et l'hôtel de ville un fourgon
vient de se garer devant cette entrée ou
s'est engouffré il y a maintenant une
petite demi heure le chef de l'état
emmanuel macron qui est arrivé donc dans
la cité phocéenne aujourd'hui et qui est
censé y rester trois jours jusqu'à
vendredi
on l'a vu un gym
les termes les thèmes qui seront abordés
en rapport d'ailleurs avec un plan
d'action qui va être dévoilée par le
chef de l'état un sécurité éducation
logement transport et même environnement
les enjeux politiques sur place à
marseille dépasse largement les intérêts
locaux ont sans doute parce qu'on peut
désormais considérer qu'il était en
campagne présidentielle comme beaucoup
le suppose oui alors il va il va être
dans cette position là le plus longtemps
possible c'est à dire cette espèce de
double casquette du président en actions
qui mène des réformes qui va sur le
terrain pour essayer d'expliquer son
action mais surtout ceux projetés c'est
à dire que là on est plus dans la
gestion la vie quotidienne
immédiate on est sur une ce que va
chercher à emmanuel macron s'est créé
une projection vers l'avenir et à
commencer par le prochain quinquennat
donc là la façon dont il va présenter le
plan j'imagine que on va être sur un
plan qui va à vue l'ampleur du plan qui
va s'étendre sur plusieurs années et qui
va enjamber la prochaine élection
présidentielle a lieu aux proches donc
inquiet par les d'ampleur du plan on a
une idée de du budget qui va être
allouée alors on annonce plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros ça devrait
dépasser le milliard d'euros rien que le
le plan pour pour l'école puisqu'il va y
avoir 200 l'établissement de colère qui
vont être rénovés à marseille rien que
sur le plan de l'éducation ça devrait
atteindre quasiment le milliard d'euros
donc on est vraiment sur des sommes
astronomiques et donc sur l'ensemble du
plan on devrait dépasser largement le le
le
le milliard d'euros
mais tout ça pour dire que en effet il
ya sept vraiment cette volonté de se
projeter sur la presse présidentielle
sur le prochain quinquennat et
d'ailleurs au niveau national il ya
aussi cette résonance en toujours entre
ce déplacement de deux de ses trois
portes ferment qui va être finalement
assez local et puis ce qui va vouloir
être fait au niveau national puisque
emmanuel macron va présenter dans les
prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines un grand plan d'investissements
de plusieurs milliards d'euros là aussi
à l'échelle nationale à l'horizon 2030
classe et ça va être le gros thème de la
rentrée des manuels mâcon en dehors de
ce déplacement à marseille s'est projeté
la france sur les dix prochaines années
et réussir à combattre les maux français
à commencer par l'insécurité mais aussi
renforcer l'administration
avoir des réseaux de transports plus
efficaces
avoir de la 5g sur tout le territoire
voilà renforcer la couverture en haut
débit même dans l'est dans les campagnes
réduire les fractures françaises
finalement à l'horizon des dix
prochaines années et donc évidemment
c'est là on comprend que finalement
emmanuel macron n'est plus vraiment dans
la position de chef d'état gestionnaire
mais surtout dans celle d'un candidat
qui se projette sur un prochain
quinquennat alors à quel moment fera
t-il sont entrés officiellement dans la
campagne présidentielle qu est-ce qui va
quel est le moment quel est l'événement
qui va décider de de son annonce il va
il va rentrer en campagne le plus tard
possible comme l'ont fait ses
prédécesseurs à l'exception françois
l'on puisse s'il n'a pas été candidat à
sa propre succession mais nicolas
sarkozy c'était la même chose vraiment
profiter de cette double casquette et de
sept
finalement de cette porosité entre le
rôle de chef de l'état à deux candidats
le plus longtemps possible puisqu'une
fois qu'on est candidat on sort
justement de cet avantage comparatif
qu'on a par rapport à ses adversaires en
étant chef de l'état et il ya des choses
aussi toute bête qui sont le financement
de la campagne c'est à dire quand il
sera président candidat il ne pourra
plus compter sur les moyens de l'elysée
pour se déplacer pendant trois jours
avec toute la sécurité c'est on se rend
pas compte là on voit les images mais
c'est un dispositif de sécurité
absolument gargantuesque qui a toute la
vie le centre-ville de 2,2 de marseille
qui complètement bouclée et donc ça il
pourra plus faire ça quand il sera
simple candidat donc quand certains
reproches l'ambiguïté si ce n'est le
mystère toujours autour de l'entrée d'un
président sortant officiellement dans
une campagne présidentielle c'est
essentiellement pour des raisons
budgétaires
financière plutôt que politique on va
dire ou non mais c'est aussi il ya aussi
des raisons politiques puisque
finalement c'est ce que je disais il ya
sept ya vraiment cet intérêt à conserver
ce rôle qui permet à la fois
d'intervenir en tant que chef de l'état
par exemple sur de la gestion de crise
internationale ce café emmanuel macron
parce qu'il a essayé de faire plutôt au
niveau de la crise afghane avec cette
tentative de création de créer une safe
zone au coeur de kaboul
à l'onu c'est des choses qu'on que fait
un président et qui va continuer à faire
jusqu'à la fin de son quinquennat et
c'est ce qu'attendent les français je
veux dire les français attendre d'un
président à ce qui préside jusqu'à là
jusqu'au dernier jour il doit y avoir
une continuité de l'action de l'état et
donc forcément il va chercher à jouer ce
double rôle jusque le plus longtemps
possible et c'est tout dans son intérêt
donc il ya évidemment aussi un intérêt
politique à
maintenir cette confusion se pourrait-il
malgré tout que emmanuel mâcon n'y aille
pas c'est absolument très peu probable
il faudrait vraiment qu'il ya une
circonstance atténuante il a lui même
évoqué dans une mine dans une interview
qu'il avait donnée aux médias brut qui
avaient duré plusieurs heures il avait
lui-même dit peut-être que je serai
empêcher d'aller à l'élection
présidentielle c'était il ya quelques
mois c'était une époque un peu
différente on était encore en pleine
crise du duc au vide et certaines
viendrait policiers rien et voilà
contexte de violences policières très
important on va dire que depuis le
paysage c'est plutôt éclaircies pour
emmanuel macron à la fois sur le plan de
la crise sanitaire on peut peut-être
espérer retrouver une vie normale dont
les les prochaines semaines berlin
espère et puis du point de vue politique
il ya un peu moins de tension alors il
ya toujours ces ses attente très forte
de la part des français sur le terrain
de la sécurité il va essayer d'y
apporter des réponses mais en tout cas
il n'y a pas d'obstacle majeur qui
empêcherait aujourd'hui une candidature
d' emmanuel macron à sa propre
succession est en tout cas tout se
prépare autour de lui dans cette
perspective là à priori sauf événement
perturbations un trait prévu et qu'on ne
peut absolument pas jamais exclure étant
donné le quinquennat qu'on vient de
vivre
emmanuel on sera bel et bien candidat à
sa propre succession on vous enregistre
à gimat wayne balle jaune profite je
veux pas prendre de paris mais à ckac
elle est là la coiffe des invités
d'emmanuel macro aujourd'hui est ce que
les français lui font confiance qu'est
ce que disent les les derniers sondages
en la matière justement sa popularité
est plutôt haut rang au sein aujourd'hui
il est à 41 % si mes souvenirs sont bons
de popularité c'est 10 points de plus là
encore je le dis ça de mémoire mais je
crois que c'est à peu près ça dix points
de plus que nicolas sarkozy à la même
période à huit mois de la présidentielle
c'est plus de 20 points de plus que
françois hollande qui était aux
alentours de 15 16% à cette époque là
c'est il faut mesurer l'écart quand même
après toutes les crises vécues par
emmanuel macron le col vide et avant
cela la crise à gilet jaune et bien
finalement il est plutôt dans une bonne
position pour aborder cette
présidentielle et les sondages disaient
également la même chose puisque tous les
sondages aujourd'hui le donne qualifier
au second tour face à marine le pen
alors après ça va ce ça va peut-être
être plus compliqué au second tour on va
voir comment les choses sont vont
évoluer en huit mois tout peut changer
c'est absolument impossible de se
projeter à abu mois de la présidentielle
on l'a vu d'ailleurs sur l'élection de
2017 à l'époque c'était alors juppé 1
qui devait remporter la présidentielle
on a vu toute sa vie dans ce qui s'est
passé mais en tout cas au jour
d'aujourd'hui 20 balles à dire avec
certains cette expression aujourd'hui en
tout cas emmanuel macron est plutôt dans
une bonne posture pour entamer cette
campagne présidentielle vous parlez de
françois hollande et des 20 points qui
le séparent et à la même époque on va
dire
de l'élection présidentielle la
précédente échéance même si françois
hollande ne s'est pas représenté
françois hollande disait il ya une
semaine en tout cas c'était une formule
qui a été reprise à partir d'un livre de
galles tchèque allofs sur le couple
macron françois hollande disait
d'emmanuel macron il ne croit en rien il
n'a aucune conviction c'est une sacrée
pic est ce qu'elle est parvenue aux
oreilles du principal intéressé y at il
répondu non il n'y a pas répondu il me
répondra évidemment pas on sait très
bien que
tous les ponts ont été rompues entre
emmanuel macron et françois hollande
depuis ce que françois hollande
considère comme une trahison
de la part d' emmanuel macron il faut
quand même se souvenir les conditions
dans lesquelles tout cela s'est déroulé
emmanuel macron qui était secrétaire
général de l'elysée puis qui est devenu
qui a été nommé par emmanuel macron par
françois hollande au ministre de
l'économie et puis qui a finalement un
peu trahi
son père politique donc évidemment que
la rancoeur de la part de françois
hollande qui l'expriment
la haie et qui exprime ce que beaucoup
de français pensent c'est à dire qu'en
fait
le principal problème d' emmanuel macron
encore aujourd'hui c'est de savoir
qui est cet homme qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent qu'est ce qui représente qu
est-ce qu il incarne politiquement est
ce que c'est un homme de gauche est ce
que c'est un homme de droite est ce que
c'est un homme hésitant politiquement
qui varie selon les contextes les
actualités et les intérêts politiques
tout ça c'est tout ça c'est des
questions auxquelles les français n'ont
pas encore obtenu de réponse claire en
quatre ans est donc le principal défi
des manuels macron sur cette campagne
pourrait pour revenir à ce sujet là ça
va être justement aussi dans de lever le
voile sur sa vraie personnalité
politique et d'apporter une forme
d'authenticité politique à son programme
et à la façon dont il veut emmener la
france sur un éventuel prochain
quinquennat donc la formulation de ces
un peu vachard la formulation de
françois lancien ça s'explique par un
contexte politique mais sur le fond il
tape assez juste si vous nous rejoignez
en direct vous venez de voir sur ces
images nous avons les images en direct
depuis marseille depuis l'hôtel de ville
de marseille où se trouve le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron arrivé un peu
plus tôt cet après midi il doit y rester
trois jours dans la cité phocéenne ça ce
sont des images de son arrivée un peu
plus tôt tout à l'heure mais lacombe
raccompagner
d'une petite dizaine de ministres qui
doivent
aborder des thématiques concernant les
transports l'insécurité l'éducation
l'environnement également emmanuel
macron doit également dévoiler un plan
d'urgence pour la ville de marseille un
déplacement local on va dire mais qui
allie portée nationale puisque vous ne
l'oublié pas et vous n'avez pas oublié
on vous l'a rappelé également que dans
huit mois elle nous allons tous voter
pour l'élection présidentielle
olympe dg sur le chat du figaro sur
figaro live vous demande j mais vous
avez déjà répondu tout à l'heure on peut
peut-être répondre de nouveau malgré toi
olympe pourquoi emmanuel macron at-il
tant tardé à s'occuper de marseille
c'est une c'est vraiment la question que
je posais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
celle c'est principal reproche qui est
battu et qui va lui être envoyée sur
c'est sur ces trois jours
avec aussi le reproche de l'opportunisme
politique à quelques mois de la
présidentielle mais pourquoi avoir tant
tardé voilà c'est c'est vrai que
finalement le je parlais tout à l'heure
du drame de la rue d'aubagne
ces deux immeubles qui se sont effondrés
qui était le symbole de l'insalubrité
de marseille en tout cas de l'ultra
centre
de marseille c'était en 2018 c'était en
2018 c'était avant l'élection municipale
est finalement encore une fois le
constat a été fait l'essentiel du
constat a été fait alors certes il ya
une une aggravation malheureusement mais
forcément vu qu'on s'occupe pas de la
ville ça ne cesse de s'aggraver
delà de la situation à marseille et puis
alors il ya peu il ya peut-être un
facteur d'explication qui est politique
et qui est que au début du quinquennat
on était encore sous le mandat de jean
claude gaudin à la mairie de marseille
et que finalement emmanuel macron
n'avait pas d'intérêt politique à
apporter une aide à jean claude gaudin
qui était dans l'opposition qui n'a
mon petit d'entre eux n'est pas de
relation tumultueuse avec emmanuel
macron mais en tout cas qui n'était pas
dans son camp et là avec benoît payan
justement c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure on est peut-être
sous la forme d'un nouveau partenariat
alors certes emmanuel benoît paillé en
terre socialiste et donc il est plutôt
dans l'opposition également mais c'est
un pragmatique et c'est quelqu'un qui
peut rentrer dans une relation donnant
donnant entre marseille la mairie de
marseille et l'état s'étaient pas le cas
certainement avec jean claude gaudin et
donc c'est peut-être aussi un facteur
d'explication
du tempo et du 2 et du fait que ce plan
ne débouche sur quelque chose de concret
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est manuel macombe
va apparaître comme le sauveur de
marseille comme certains sur le chat du
figaro live sur youtube parle du sauveur
de marseille oui mais c'est le rôle
c'est le rôle d'un président de la
république et au sens plus large de du
gouvernement français de
dalé
alors sauvé c1 c'est un mot un peu
messianique mais en tout cas c'est
d'aller en tout cas on soutient une
population en difficulté il se trouve
que les marseillais aujourd'hui
connaissent un certain nombre de
difficultés sur plusieurs sujets la
sécurité le logement l'emploi l'école
les transports
l'écologie il ya beaucoup il ya
énormément de sujets et finalement
marseille est un petit laboratoire de
tous les problèmes que rencontrent les
français dans leur quotidien à l'échelle
nationale et c'est pour ça aussi que
emmanuel macron choisi marseille comme
comme comme symbole dans sa donc dans le
lancement de ce qui pourrait être sa
campagne présidentielle
donc le sauveur de marseille oui il va
essayer en tout cas d'apporter
un soutien et de l'ada à ce territoire
mais je doute qu'ils se tombent dans le
piège de se prétendre être lui-même le
sauveur de marseille puisque les
résultats si jamais il devait y en avoir
ne se verront que dans cinq à dix ans
c'est sur ce débat là qu'ils tablent
d'ailleurs puisque les centaines de
millions d'euros qui sont alloués à ce
budget qui va être annoncé je crois
demain si je me trouve devant sont
prévus pour être dépensés au fil du
temps et sur un peu plus tôt long terme
comme vous le disiez quand on lit que la
majorité se prépare à faire campagne
pour emmanuel macron qu'est ce que cela
signifie et la majorité vous parlez de
la majorité le président a seulement et
bien la majorité présidentielle alors
c'est peut-être elle qui est justement
aux avant-postes en de cette campagne
qui se prépare je parlais tout à l'heure
de l'elysée qui
vraiment la machine d'état de l'elysée
qui elle va rester le plus longtemps
possible dans cette nature là mais la
majorité présidentielle ll est sur une
fonction beaucoup plus politique et
c'est elle qui est déjà aux avant-postes
et qui prépare
on va dire l'entrée en orbite en
campagne de d'emmanuel macron qui se
passera certainement dans l'est dans les
derniers dans les dernières semaines
avant le avant le scrutin mais la
majorité est déjà en train de plancher
sur le sujet elle et elle va être
associé d'ailleurs aux différents sujets
qui vont être seul à rentrer notamment
le plan d'investissement 2030 dont jeu
dont je parlais il ya quelques minutes
c'est elle qui va devoir aller porter la
bonne parole dans les circonscriptions
sur les sur les marchés auprès des
français pour dire mais regardez
emmanuel macron il vous a il a été notre
présent pendant cinq ans mais il a aussi
des idées pour la suite et donc c'est
finalement c'est là dessus que emmanuel
macron va pouvoir compter parce que il à
l'un l'une des difficultés des médiocres
on sait qu'il a finalement un maillage
territorial politique très limitée il
n'a pas dû locaux pas de mer pas de
conseillers régionaux pas de conseillers
municipaux donc sur le terrain c'est
vraiment les députés
la majorité si elle va devoir jouer un
peu les apôtres pour porter la bonne
parole
présidentielle et donc il va y avoir
cette rentrée parlementaire qui va se
dérouler à angers dans quelques jours ça
va être en présence de
christophe castaner qui est le patron
des députés de la république en marche
et donc ça va être un des sujets comment
se projeter déjà dans la campagne
présidentielle pour parler de christophe
castaner mais il est un autre élément
très important pour emmanuel macron qui
est edouard philippe dont on entend de
nouveau parlé ces derniers jours quelles
ambitions à edouard philippe derrière
l'accompagnement on va dire des manuels
mâcon vers sa candidature pour l'instant
edouard philippe à une position plutôt
clair qui est la position d'un soutien à
emmanuel macron avec
l'existence d'un pôle qui lui est propre
au sein de la majorité il va d'ailleurs
lancer le 8 octobre si mes souvenirs
sont bons au havre dans sa mairie son
propre mouvement politique ça va être
très intéressant à observer et donc il
va chercher à continuer à structurer un
certain nombre d'élus autour de lui là
il était d'ailleurs dimanche à
fontainebleau avec une trentaine de
mères qui sont des mères macron
compatible wii soutiennent emmanuel
macron mais qui sont des maires de
droite et qui vient qui viennent grâce à
edouard philippe renforcer ce pôle
majoritaire dont je parlais est donc
identique il va vraiment avoir ce rôle
là auprès d'emmanuel macron pour essayer
d'agrandir au maximum le cercle du
maquereau nisme sur sa droite et ça va
être l'un des problèmes aussi que va
devoir affronter les républicains le
candidat des républicains c'est
justement edouard philippe qui va avoir
cette position un peu intermédiaire
entre les elle fut rien et la république
est en marche et qui va chercher un peu
à gratter du côté de sa droite en faveur
des manuels macron et puis après
l'histoire nous dira qu'elle quel rôle
jouera edouard philippe dans un second
temps si jamais est-ce que ça qu'a
commencé mais annuel
anticiper une potentielle trahison non
mais pour certains qui n'ont annoncé une
trahison à la façon qu'ils habitent non
ça c'est pour l'instant en tout cas
c'est assez parlé d'un ce crédible la
paix sur la preuve il faut il faut je
pense que edouard philippe est conscient
du fait qu' il ne peut pas s'affronter
affronter de manière frontale emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui qu'ils n'auraient pas
grand chose à y gagner et que finalement
ils jouent soit le coup d'après soit une
éventuelle défaillance de la part des
mails macron dont on ne sait jamais ce
qui peut arriver en dans la vie
politique et et et heureusement plein de
surprises sinon seraient pas là pour la
commenter mais voilà en tout cas il se
sait sur qui ils structurent quelque
chose il se tient prêt au cas où mais
c'est assez peu probable voire
totalement improbable que de voir
edouard philippe s'ériger en adversaire
d'emmanuel macron sur cette prochaine
présidentielle merci beaucoup je me
verras c'est en arrive à la fin de ce
direct nous étions en direct et vous le
voyez sur ces images nous avons encore
les images en direct depuis l'hôtel de
ville de marseille
si julien qu'une aile qui est en régie
peut nous le montre est donc là c'est
les images que nous avons eu un petit
peu plus tôt tout à l'heure
effectivement de l'entrée des manuels
macron et de certains officiels dans
l'hôtel de ville de marseille il est
arrivé
le chef de l'état tout à l'heure il doit
y rester trois jours annoncé un plan
d'urgence pour la ville de marseille de
très grande envergure de plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros
pour aider à améliorer la sécurité de la
ville les transports l'urbanisme
l'éducation également et puis
l'environnement qui sont autant de
questions et de thèmes qui seront aussi
essentielle à une future campagne
présidentielle que porterait le chef de
l'état merci encore de nous avoir suivis
nous ne savons pas dans combien de temps
le chef de l'état sortira de cet hôtel
de ville il rencontre les élus en ce
moment j'aime la race et de préciser
qu'il voyait également jean-luc
mélenchon qui est je le rappelle député
des bouches du rhône et à ce titre est
également présent sur place vous vouliez
ajouter quelques joly eelv a priori
faire une
visites dans les quartiers nord de
marseille est une ville qui n'était pas
prévu au programme on vient de on vient
de l'apprendre avant justement de se
rendre dans un commissariat ou aux
alentours de 18 heures où on imagine qui
fera des premières annonces sur les
renforts policiers qui seront apportées
à la ville de marseille
merci encore j'aimerais assez pour vos
lumières votre expertise sur ce sujet
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis en
direct sur figaro live et sur youtube
merci pour vos questions également et
votre participation il vous retrouve
très vite sur figaro live à bientôt